la suite notre feuilleton à présent nous
sommes toujours aux côtés des
spécialistes du ciel dans les coulisses
de météo france
après avoir passé en revue leurs
activités en mer et en montagne nous
allons voir qu'ils participent aussi à
la lutte contre les feux de forêt ce
sont des vigies essentiel pour les
pompiers qui sont sur le terrain
départs de feu à proximité de marseille
au centre opérationnel de zone près
d'aix-en-provence le colonel mené sur
les qui vivent quatre canadairs qui
rentrent du gher également le feu risque
de s'étendre aux habitations
ici les pompiers contrôler tout le quart
sud est de la france dans la lutte
contre les feux de forêt à deux pas de
la salle opérationnelle des
météorologues scrute les cartes de
prévision ils sont présents pendant
toute la saison des feux et sont un
dialogue permanent avec la sécurité
civile
départs de feu largage des deux trackers
et deux dash hollandais en renfort sur
ce seul à marseille toutes les données
sont immédiatement échangé 37km rang
moyen vitesse et direction des vents
vitesse de propagation des feux dur en
ce sens des informations directement
répercutée sur le terrain où l'incendié
sera maîtrisé en quelques heures
la cellule météo
nous confirment des données que l'on
prend très vite en compte donc là en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui le paramètre le
plus important pour nous c'est la
composante vent qui peut nous permettre
d'anticiper l'évolution défavorable de
chantier c'est la dernière réunion de la
journée l'heure pour les prévisionnistes
d'évaluer les risques pour les jours à
venir
alors demain le mistral et la tramontane
mollissent un niveau sévère on n'a plus
d'autre et c'est le danger s'éloigne les
nuages arrivent ils étaient touche à sa
fin au centre météo france de toulouse
ces clés ouvre les portes du temps les
nuages les pluies les saisons sylvie en
fait la collection
là je vais vous montrer des cartons
archives qui contiennent des données
méthodologiques de des dom tom des
terres australes kerguelen crozet mais
aussi tous les départements français
les anciennes colonies d'afrique des
dizaines de milliers de documents à
l'exemple de saint pierre et miquelon
des données assez ancienne quand même
puisque on remonte à 1936 des relevés
mensuels d'observation à saint pierre et
miquelon l'orne à la température
minimale minimum et maximum de la
journée et une moyenne de 1 degré 2 ce
qui n'est pas très chaud à saint pierre
et miquelon en janvier 1936 toutes ces
mesures sont enregistrés et numérisés
oui c'est mieux
un fabuleux trésor de chiffres qu'elle
enrichit chaque année de 2 millions de
données les plus anciens de reliques
remonte au xviiie siècle alors relever
d'un deuxième siècle qui étaient
archivés mai à la bibliothèque de météo
france
un genre de bulletins mensuels et celui
là bon je n'ose pas trop le manipuler
tellement ni abîmer jeu jean poiret pas
le marqueur logique le jeu histoire oui
kim et détective histoire climatologie
en fait c'est la mémoire du mythe roger
document car pour prévoir le temps qu'il
fera demain ou dans 100 ans
il faut avoir connaissance du temps
qu'il a fêté hier et avant-hier un enjeu
de taille et une époque au cumin
certains bonjour je les forces affirmer
tout france je vous appelle pour le vol
megapoli 3 d'aujourd'hui ici à pontoise
et pilote de météo france prépare une
mission très spéciale
un vol dans des nuages toxiques les
nuages de pollution autour de paris les
scientifiques confectionne
méticuleusement les pièges
je dépose des filtres présence dans ce
mécanisme là qu'on appelle un porte-
filtre ce qui va permettre la collecte
des particules donc sur les petits
filtre blanc qu'on revienne déposer
ensuite on va aller on va les traiter
pour déterminer quel type de particules
sont présentes
l'avion est armé jusqu'aux ailes pour la
chasse aux polluants des entrées d'air
des capteurs des sondes
là bas tu peux commencer
e